hey was geht ab willkommen bei einem
neuen video ich hoffe euch geht es gut
leute ich habe mir für heute ein video
überlegt und zwar sind wir hier rat in
griechenland und haben hier ein kleines
ja ich würde mal sagen haus oder so da
appartement im griechischen stil und es
ist auch für mich das erste mal dass ich
in griechenland bin deswegen habe ich
mir natürlich überlegt dass ich euch das
mal zeige
und wir machen heute eine kleine hut ich
zeige euch mal wie es hier so aus sie
was am anfang noch sehr sehr wichtig ist
zu sagen ich hab jetzt in den letzten
zwei tagen übels aufgelesen alexy muss
jetzt einen besen essen
leute ich hab das ja gesagt und ich
werde es auch natürlich versuchen
einzuhalten weil ich will jetzt auch
nicht einfach das ganz ignorieren
allerdings kommt mal kurz rein es ist
sehr sehr schwer wenn man irgendwo an
einem fremden ort ist ein wesen zu
finden ja hier gibt es nirgendwo im
besen und ich habe keine ahnung wo ich
einen besen herbekommen soll aber das
video kommt auf jeden fall die woche ich
werde weiter suchen und ich denke das
war ein besen finden so also dazu kurz
die aufklärung und jetzt fangen wir an
ja das ist unser haus und das sind
glaube ich 60 quadratmeter so dass jetzt
nicht brutal groß ist aber es ist
wirklich wirklich richtig richtig schön
eingerichtet natürlich kommt auch dem
reise kanal von uns zuerst natürlich
auch ganz oben im video beschreibung
verlinkt ein cooles video dazu also ich
werde jetzt hier nicht die krassesten
aufnahmen raus und es kommen auf diese
reise kanal deswegen abonniert und auf
jeden fall erreichen haben
das ist natürlich auch genauso in
deutschland gibt
das ist halt das einzige wo ich sagen
würde dass es nicht so bei der firma ist
da und das bett ist da oben und da gibt
es leider keinen fernseher regel weiter
hier ist die küche das ist irgendwie
witzig hier gibt es einfach ein ja es
gibt kein rufen warum auch immer
da wird zu viel schaum hier oben mit
einem fallschirm gefäßen also das sind
so sachen die hat man eigentlich in
jedem appartement so leute hier ist der
fernseher der absolut tolle programme
hat auch aus deutschland das problem ist
keines davon funktioniert und hier ist
der tisch wo wir noch nie gegessen haben
da habe ich meine kamera sachen aufgetan
leute hier die drohne damit kann ich
euch mal kurzen aufnahme zeigen gleich
wie das hier so von oben aussieht weil
das ist echt man richtig richtig schöner
view the money hat aber die terrasse
zeige euch natürlich auch rechte vor wir
gehen jetzt erst mal hoch habe ich
vorher noch nie gesehen das ist
wahrscheinlich so typisch griechisch
also kommen sie bitte mit cool aus wenn
hier unten diese nicht erleuchten das
einfach mal nach oben da haben wir keine
herz ja und zwar haben wir hier ein bett
nur leute nach kleinen strapazen
das hier ist das bett ist echt bequem
keine ahnung was für eins aber der typ
dem was sie gerade hat gesagt jetzt the
best bett in santorini so genau genommen
wir sind hier übrigens auf santorini
habe ich ja schon gesagt das ist eine
absurde santorini ist eine insel in der
nähe von mykonos oder so ungefähr
geplante heißt und ungenau und wenn man
hier mal weitergehen
hat man
diesen will ich springe bis runter das
echt cool weil er kann ich mal so hoch
war wie ich hätte gern da sind also dann
bringst du das wär ja das ist das
appartement oder ja ich weiß gar nicht
wie man es nennt haus kein plan
so leute wir befinden uns jetzt ich habe
dieses ding jetzt abgeschraubt das hat
vielleicht bei einigen fünf schlechtes
bild gesagt ich weiß es nicht tut mir
leid auf jeden fall nur noch mit der
kamera und wenn man jetzt mal
nach hinten geht kompensieren haben wir
hier so ein schrank und die ganzen
kleinen drin dann wird sogar automatisch
das licht an und was ich mich frage
moment kommt mal kurz mit ihr nicht ja
ja ich weiß so wenn man hier als weiter
geht und spaß ist das war wir haben wir
die dusche wenn man sich heute die
seiner schwarz ich habe auch immer
und wenn man hier raus und schon kommt
einfach hier hinter ist ein moment ist
es mit bezogen hier ist ein traum der
hammer überhaupt nicht zu betreten ist
[Musik]
so leute und jetzt kommen wir eigentlich
zum highlight das ist wirklich echt cool
und richtig wir sind hier nicht auf der
seite die viele von euch bestimmt kennt
von irgendwelchen fotos oder so wo diese
ganzen waisenhäuser sind sondern auf der
anderen seite hier ist es ein bisschen
ruhiger trotzdem ziemlich hoch und dann
kann wenn man es jetzt mal kommt man mit
ja das ist da draußen bereich wir haben
ja einen swimmingpool
ich werde mein arschkalt ist ne also es
ist echt mega schön eingerichtet und man
kann sogar das meer sehen von hier und
da habe ich mir gedacht nehme ich euch
mal kurz drohen schott auf deswegen
fliegen wir mal kurz mit der drohne hoch
und dann könnt ihr sehen dass es
wirklich echt schön aussieht und
griechenland gefällt
[Musik]
hier kann man sich dann noch hinsetzen
abends und das coole ist auch hier neben
uns könnten theoretisch noch welche
wurden und da auch aber da wurde einfach
keiner wir sind hier eigentlich die
einzigen
und wenn man mal runter geht wir können
ja einmal hier lang gehen wirklich eine
sehr sehr schöne aussicht und davon
manchmal große schiffe lang
wir gehen jetzt einkaufen wir haben hier
so ein quatsch
diese vier riesigen teile vierrädrigen
sagt man doch so nenne diese gefährten
mit vier rädern diese gefährt mit genau
und das steht da unten damit fahren
jetzt einkaufen das macht richtig spaß
hier lang sofort einfach weil hier
dieses straßen so hügelig sind und hier
fand kaum autos also leute da sehen wir
uns vielleicht noch und dann war's das
das kann ich eigentlich mit einer go pro
film dann ist die kammer qualität nicht
so gut aber besser als das die kaputt
geht es noch nach oben da wenn ich die
kleidung vor gefallen hat verlässt auf
jeden fall nicht den reise kanal zu
abonnieren da wird ein cooles video
folgen
und wir sind gerade mal am zweiten tag
hier also wenn er war noch nicht mehr
bestimmt war noch gar nicht mehr
heutigen sonntag wieder zurück
und ja wir sehen uns und denkt daran
irgendwann kommt das wesentliche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so leute wir sind jetzt fertig mit
meisten das besen video folgt natürlich
habe ich mir versprochen ich weiß nein
ich war wie gesagt vielleicht morgen
vielleicht übermorgen vielleicht auch
erst am freitag keine ahnung ansonsten
wünsche euch eine schöne buch hat rein